Android patterns for performance
Do you know what determines the slowness of a given application?
Those wheeling wheels are time consuming and annoying to the user
While the background activity tries to load some user interface (UI) data.
My name is Colt McCannless.
I say this is the most annoying UI pattern on Android.
This problem is actually easier to solve than your expectations.
We are in 2015 now.
Most modern applications derive all of their UI content
Depending on information from some server resources.
This is an easy process.
Ask the server for updated data.
When you receive it, update your UI to include the changes.
It's easy, is not it?
But the problem here is what the user sees
While waiting for you to bring up updated information.
Of course, if the user uses the application regularly,
The screen is likely to be filled with data.
But when you respond to an important contextual change
Or download the application for the first time after a long time,
No data to populate the preview screen.
You must set a swivel wheel on a blank screen.
The solution here is very simple, which is caching.
In the past, I have actually brought in a valid block of UI information
Except for the first time of course download.
But in any case, despite the data provided,
Your app can use that information in these situations
Where new data is not fetched yet.
So this is the case.
After successfully fetching some UI data,
Make a sequence with a steady storage
At a certain time stamp so you can know the age of the information.
In the case of normal startup,
You can use the current UI interface data to start drawing the screen
Start commanding your server
To bring up the latest information.
Of course, you still have to give a signal to the user
And tell him what kind of new information is being brought.
But at least looks at a real screen
Instead of a blank UI with a trivial rotating wheel is not it?
This is already easy.
Temporarily store UI data
So you can use it later when you have to wait
So that the server gives you some updates.
This is indeed an easy process.
By the way, it should be noted that there is a correct and wrong method
To store this data in disk.
You must first use a binary sequence format
Because it produces lower file sizes and faster performance
From eye-readable artefacts such as JSON or XML.
Second, it took some time
To find the best way to temporarily store this information.
One way to do this is to store it in a cluster
But if the user interface is based on several complex queries
Through that data,
Canceling the download sequence may not be the best idea
Compared to storage in the SQLite database
Which may be a much faster solution.
But in fact,
Any of these options is better than displaying a blank screen with a swivel wheel.
Even if you have the fastest application on our planet,
Your employees will feel unreasonably slow.
The user feeling is the main idea;
Check out the remaining Android Performance Patterns videos.
Do not miss joining the Google+ community
To ask other questions as well.
So keep calm, collect your code information
Always remember that performance is important.